so I woke up this morning and I saw all
over Twitter this video about this
pineapple that you can just peel this
video is all over tick-tock it's all
over Twitter I've even seen it all so
much morning news channels it's like
gone completely viral for whatever
reason and so I'm gonna test this theory
and see if it's real
hey I'm all have you been on Twitter
lately have you seen the pineapple thing
you wanna try okay so in theory we
should have to just pull one of these
off because that's what Twitter told me
yeah cuz okay in my like my vision here
is where we have to like cut spill and
then this these little little thingies
oh okay no I mean now I don't know
we're trying so you want to come over
help no but really oh oh em all you this
something okay but it's worth it I think
once we get a couple out it will become
very easy okay you think we have to cut
the top out maybe let's try that okay I
got a little niblet I think it was
really key to cut the top okay so should
we ask one for the time out okay this is
[Music]
well I've learned that sometimes Twitter
trends don't actually work what is your
technique going in wing it
yeah there we go Wow yeah you throw your
meat oh you got a little bit of problem
get in there oh oh wait it has to be cut
because you got it if you look at it and
look at all this okay so if I come in
here with a knife and you just kind of
like poco a room so if you grab that one
it's pre time you get off of this one
yeah okay oh wow
Wow
[Music]
yeah we also learned that you can't take
everything on the internet at face value
sometimes you have to put in extra work
and the way that things look like on the
inner are not what they actually are
[Music]